hello and welcome to the fourteenth
fundamental investing with the use of
Python programming where we left off I
will just bring it up we were generating
a chart this was just I think what what
are we doing net income yeah it was just
net income here and we don't have the
date or anything like that on there but
just showing you guys basic projection
so now what I want to do is graph the
other the other two things and show you
guys that and eventually we will be
moving into including in our other
program though I think what I'll do is
I'll at least show the basics of
graphing all three of these things and I
think I'm gonna have to just break down
and show you guys how to convert the
dates and then make this one look at
least acceptable so anybody that maybe
doesn't want to include it with their
like some people might not care at all
about the RSI or the MACD so I want to
make everybody have to go that route
although I do you know highly suggest
that you guys check that out there's a
lot of really great even if you don't
care about the RSI or the MACD there's a
lot of really good information there as
far as like graphing and matplotlib is
concerned so if you're not into that
stuff so highly suggest you check it out
but I figure I better not force
everybody to do that so I'm not gonna
anyway so so we're gonna do is we're
gonna graph the other two things and
then I'll help you all fix the dates and
one more thing and and then we'll start
moving it into the Yahoo thing well the
screener and then we'll the final step
will be into the the Python charting
tutorial series that way not everybody
has to do it so anyway what we're gonna
do I'm just going to literally copy and
paste this this first array and that way
all we have to do is just edit in the
new terms and so since basically formats
all the same so this one was read date
and then this one
revenue and it's not net income array
it's Rev array and then this variable
will call our OC date this variable will
just call our OC and the thing that
we're gonna get it from is our OC array
or RS c8r but everything else stays the
same delimiter still a comma still
converts the same all that so we don't
really need to change that now we
actually need to we've converted this
basically to an umpire array now what we
need to do is actually graph this stuff
right so fig equals plot figure that's a
the same plot shows stays the same but
then here we need to plot two more axes
so paste paste we'll call this X YZ axis
to this axes will be X 3 and the stuff
that we're going to plot is different we
have Rev date so I'll just copy paste
this one was and then revenue and then
we had our OC day paste and then our OC
good and the last thing we want to do is
we're going to put it up on into this
grid so actually let's just change this
grid to be let's just make it a six by
six for now it doesn't really matter but
we'll do that so this one starts at zero
at zero this one will start at to zero
and this one will start at four zero
then we want to start editing rowspan so
all these will be they'll spend two rows
and they'll all span
six columns now let's get to plot a
really basic one so let's see where we
stand make sure we did everything all
righty
sure enough there we go we've got all
three plots on here the data this wasn't
that income I already forget what the
second one
a net income then the second one was
revenue and then we had return on
capital
we could add titles on these or even put
like a label on the axes I guess maybe
we can do that along with the other
edits that we're gonna make real quick
so I guess yeah let's throw that in
really quick and add the label just to
be good good little Grapher is here so 8
X 1 or actually here's what we do for
this thing's just plot Y label and this
one we are gonna call what was this net
income net income and then come down
here and you don't have to specify the
axes like it goes by what it's plotting
at the time I'm pretty sure so now we
want this is revenue and the final one
is return I said we'll do our OC just
because I don't want to run out of space
so that should do it for at least our
labels so we don't forget like what the
heck we're looking at right so let's
bring that over so now you should see
something more like this so at least you
know what you're looking at and then the
last thing now or well second to last
thing that I'm going to show you is
let's convert this to a date format now
so close out of this and what I want to
do is first I want to we're gonna kill
two birds with one stone actually so let
me show you something one last time when
this graph comes up you'll see that it
looks like this right but if you were to
say zoom in to this point here it only
zooms in this chart it doesn't do them
in these charts and a lot of times you
might want to zoom in to a specific spot
and see what the other one was doing at
that specific time now with these charts
it's not as necessary by one thing to
know is they're not lined up with each
other because this one I believe goes
all the way back to like 1999 right the
return on capital data goes back to 1999
and then one of these goes back to only
2003 and the other one I think maybe a 1
or something like that so they're not
they're not lined up correctly right so
that's that's kind of a problem so first
so we want to solve that problem and we
want to do the date issue so to kill all
those birds we want to as another
parameter here just after you specify
the shape in the starting point put
another parameter in here and it's
called share X and where do we want to
share X with a x1 and then a comma and
so that will share the axis of the x
axis with axis 1 and then I'm just going
to paste the same thing down here so now
they actually share the same axes with
each other and then while we're here
let's go ahead and edit the date and
convert the date and then I'll show you
guys what where we are now so to convert
the date since they're all sharing the X
at the same axes as axes one basically
all we have to do is convert that axis
to date format so ax 1 dot x axes dot
set underscore major underscore
formatter and then open up your
parameters M dates dot capital dat e F
capital F by the way for matter and then
within your parameters here we just
specify kind of the same it will just
copy and paste actually this is the same
stuff if you had intraday data you would
you know you'd want to have the inch
whole my goodness I can't click you
would want that but for now that's the
format that we want so now when we run
this you should see in a second when it
comes up this call is taking along there
we go
now there's actual dates here right and
see this one goes back to 1999 right
even though we can't see it if we did
scroll up well I guess it doesn't see if
you hover over it you should see down
here in the corner and when I hover over
a spot you can see this one goes back to
2001 but this one only goes back to oh
three and this one goes back to 2002 so
they're all different data sets right
but what's awesome
is now we want like let's be like okay
well we want to like look at this spot
right here it Suman to all of them even
though you only zoomed in on like one
chart you know so it can be helpful but
like I said like with this data the most
helpful point is when it comes up
initially it's not that we're going to
be zooming in on anything because it's
real there's not much it's not really
high granularity data but what's nice is
when it when it comes up these are all
aligned right so like this point here is
827 with this point which would be 27 if
I can hold my mouse straight as I went
up but anyway the data is now aligned so
you can still compare these things and
finally the only thing I'm gonna I'm
gonna change about this chart I mean you
can do all kinds of customization with
matplotlib but if you want to learn more
about that you're gonna have to do the
Python charting tutorial but the last
thing I'm going to show you guys is
we're going to fix this spacing issue
cuz that's just bothering me so to do
that and to see what you might want to
do you can click this configure subplots
button and up will pop a little window
like this and actually to be exactly
like this and what we want to do is
manage the H space which is like head
space I think so we want to bring that
up a little bit and that's probably
pretty good like a 50 point 5 3 so now
there's like these aren't like they're
not getting jumbled up too bad so that's
the last thing we'll do here and to do
that you can you adjust the plots here
so you want to have to do it by hand
every time the command for that is PLT
dotsub plots underscore adjust and you
could put any of those parameters that
we were just looking at in here but the
only one we were really going to edit
right now it's h space and we're gonna
say that equals 0.53 save that run it
and up pops a beautiful chart onload I
mean this stuff kind of runs into each
other but like I said if you want to
make your chart really epic you'll have
to watch the other tutorial and so
anyway now we have this so now what I
want to do is go back to where we were
with our Yahoo screener and anytime it
a company that matches the the PG the PE
the price-to-book all that stuff it will
not only tell us that stock but then
it's going to visit quantal and pop us
up a chart just like this for the stock
that it found so we can immediately look
at its earnings data revenue return on
capital and then obviously if you guys
wanted to throw in your own little
custom thing you could change the links
up to be whatever the heck you wanted
really so that's what we're gonna do
next and then yeah after that then we'll
connect it all together with the other
epic app that we built and we'll be
sitting pretty so anyway hopefully I'm
helping you guys out as always thanks
for watching thanks for all the support
subscriptions and until next time